this program is brought to you by Emory
University
people with lupus should share their
thoughts and how they feel with
relatives I think that as far as us
trying to reach out to people to make
them understand start at home I think
only this year have my parents started
to understand what goes on with me was
ruthlessly and I've been living in their
house that's my initial mixed connective
tissue diagnosis but because I got up
and I went to work and everything people
are always telling me you're the picture
of health especially relatives and
that's a great thing you don't want to
look ill but you want people to know
that there is something going on with
you that may not have you acting that
perky Pam that they'd like to see as
soon as I was given a copy of the
newsletter I made sure that my children
got to read it because they need to hear
me say what goes on me they'll see me in
the kitchen cooking on a Sunday and
think that I'm okay and it might be one
of my worst days ever so the don't make
the assumption that because I looked as
a particular way that I always feel this
way my kids now ask me do you feel like
doing so and I think that's just great
that is so wonderful for somebody else
to care about how you're feeling and if
you start at home family loves you most
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University